Narrator: Spider-Man is back!
Ned: Awesome!
Narrator:After the tragic
ending of "Infinity War"
a lot of us were worried about the future
of our favorite web-slinger.
But Tom Holland returns
in this fresh trailer
for "Spider-Man: Far From Home."
Although, it may leave you
with more questions than answers.
Peter: What just happened?
Narrator: Does "Far From
Home" take place before
or after "Avengers: Endgame?"
Who are the villains in this movie?
And who's Jake Gyllenhaal
supposed to be playing?
To start, "Spider-Man: Far From Home"
appears to take place after the events
of "Avengers: Endgame."
Sony producer Amy Pascal revealed
that "Spider-Man: Far
From Home" takes place
just a few minutes after
the end of "Endgame."
That makes this trailer extra special
being the only way to
get a peek at the world
after "Endgame" premieres this April.
And, let's be honest, we're all curious
who's going to survive
the Mad Titan's invasion.
So, let's take a closer look.
A lot of familiar faces make
a return in this trailer.
Marissa Tomei returns as Aunt May
who discovered Peter Parker's secret
at the end of "Homecoming."
Aunt May seems to have adjusted to
Peter's alter-ego as the two play a part
in running a homeless shelter
a story line from both the
comics and the PS4 video game.
John Favreau is back as Happy Hogan
who was a big part in the first film.
He shows up with a check
from Synchrony Bank
a little nod to the actual bank
that issues Marvel credit cards.
And it seems that Aunt May and Happy Hogan
might just be more than friends.
Happy: New dress?
Aunt May: Yes it is. How'd you know?
Peter: What just happened?
Narrator: The trailer
also nods to a character
we're all familiar with, but
have never seen in the MCU.
Uncle Ben, hinted at by the initials
on the suitcase that
Peter brings to Europe.
Peter is not alone on his trip to Europe.
Zendaya returns as Michelle "M.J." Jones
the movie's version of Mary Jane Watson.
It appears that M.J. will
be Peter's love interest
as their romance is heavily foreshadowed
throughout the trailer.
Peter: I just want to
spend some time with MJ.
I think she really likes me, dude.
Narrator: And Flash
Thompson, who just like
in the comics, bullies Peter Parker
but ironically admires
Spider-Man as a hero.
Flash: What? He looks
out for the neighborhood,
has a dope suit, and I really respect him.
Sup, dickwad?
Narrator: And of course, how can we
forget Peter's best friend, Ned?
Ned: Awesome!
Narrator: Which leads to
our first surprising reveal
the return of Nick Fury.
Considering Fury died after
the events of "Infinity War"
it seems like the character
will be brought back to life.
And judging by his first words
Nick: So nice to finally
meet you, Spider-Man.
Narrator: It seems as though they do not
encounter each other in "Endgame."
And, is this figure
next to Fury Maria Hill
also brought back from the dead?
Or someone else entirely?
A character obviously
missing from the trailer
is none other than Tony Stark
who is heavily featured with Spider-Man in
both his first appearance in
"Civil War" and "Homecoming."
And this line from Hogan
Happy: You're all alone.
Narrator: Sounds quite ominous.
Could this be hinting at the death
of Tony Stark in "Avengers: Endgame?"
Or maybe it's just Marvel trying
to throw us off the plot.
Whatever happens, the future doesn't look
so promising for Iron Man.
Also featured in the
trailer, are the many suits
Peter wears during his trip in Europe.
In the beginning, Peter wears the classic
red and blue suit that
we saw in "Homecoming."
Of course, things don't
go according to plan
as Nick Fury makes an appearance
to set Peter on a mission.
We see two main suits
featured in the trailer.
One suit that closely
resembles the classic suit
but with a darker palette and wings!
The same wings we only
briefly saw in Homecoming
are now featured more prominently
seemingly allowing Peter to effortlessly
glide through the sky.
We also get a better look at the Noir suit
from the "Spider-Man: Noir"
series set in 1933, also
featured recently in "Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse"
voiced by Nicholas Cage.
Judging by the nighttime setting
maybe this is the suit of choice
when the job requires stealth
over, well, aesthetics.
It was long rumored
that a group of villains
known as the Elementals were going
to make an appearance in the film.
The Elementals first made an appearance
in the series, "Supernatural Thrillers"
and are composed of four
extra-dimensional villains
who each control different elements.
Hellfire, who controls fire
Hydron, who controls water
and Magnum, who
manipulates earth and rock.
The only one missing is Zephyr
who has the power to control air.
But Zephyr's presence
is possibly hinted at
by this lightning when they
attack the London Bridge.
These villains, however, could also
be Sandman, Molten Man, and Hydro-Man
other super villains who also
control different elements
to fight against Spider-Man.
This is hinted at by these
numbers on the boat behind Ned.
ASM 212, alluding to the
"Amazing Spider-Man" issue 212
where Hydro-Man makes
his first appearance.
Whether the villains are
really the Elementals
or someone else, we'll
have to wait and see.
Last, but most importantly, we finally
get our first look at Mysterio
one of Spider-Man's main villains
played by Jake Gyllenhaal.
Fans of the original comic will be happy
to see him in the fishbowl
helmet featured in the comics.
The only difference is that it seems
as though Mysterio is on Spider-Man's side
fighting against the bad guys.
There have been numerous rumors
about Nick Fury teaming Spider-Man up
with Mysterio to fight the Elementals
and Mysterio being a complex,
morally ambiguous villain.
So, how does Mysterio go from fighting
alongside Spider-Man to
fighting against him?
Or, to speculate a bit, is it possible
that The Elementals are actually
just an illusion created by Mysterio
whose main power in the comics
is creating illusions
to deceive his enemies?
A similar storyline was featured
in the animated series of Spider-Man
where Mysterio used illusions
to manipulate the city,
painting Spider-Man
as the villain and himself as the hero.
Could this possibly be
what we're seeing in the trailer?
It seems like Peter's friends
are convinced that he's a hero.
Kids: Who is that guy?
- He's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one.
Narrator: Are you convinced?
So, what did you think about this trailer?
What are your theories and speculations?
Leave it in the comments,
and see you at the theaters in July.